من المؤسف للغاية أن النحل أصبح ساخنًا للغاية وسقط المشط، الجو
حار جدًا في أريزونا لدرجة أن
خلايا النحل تذوب. لم أر خلايا
النحل تذوب بهذه الطريقة من قبل تلك
الحضنة الميتة الذائبة، إنها مشكلة
جديدة نوعًا ما ومثيرة للقلق عندما ترى
المشط  مجرد الانهيار انظر إلى ما
تبقى هنا تعيش مربي النحل كريكيت ألدريتش
في فينيكس حيث حطمت حرارة الصيف الشديدة الأرقام القياسية
هذا العام، سجلت المدينة
31 يومًا متتاليًا بلغت 110
درجات أو أعلى مع ارتفاع درجات الحرارة
إلى 119 درجة.
تقول ألدريدج إنها تتسابق لإنقاذ النحل من
درجات الحرارة الحارقة نأمل أن
نجد الملكة على قيد الحياة إذا
انهارت الخلية. الخطر الأكبر هو أن
الملكة سوف يتم سحقها مباشرة إذا
ماتت الملكة فإن المستعمرة بأكملها تموت
لأنه لا يوجد نحل آخر يمكنه
وضع البيض لتجديد المستعمرات
يقول ألدريتش أن  تقتل الحرارة الشديدة
أيضًا النباتات مما يجعل الغذاء نادرًا
بالنسبة لنحل العسل. إذا انخفض عدد السكان، فلن
يتمكنوا من إدارة جميع المهام
التي يجب أن تحدث في الخلية، وهذا
يشمل إبقائها باردة بدرجة كافية حتى
لا تذوب مرة أخرى، هذا هو المزيج
كميات قليلة من الطعام في الصحراء
الآن بحيث لا تكون أرقام B عالية
كما يمكن أن تكون
وغير قادرة على إبقاء الخلية باردة
في الخارج